il va falloir sont des questions sur la
cuisine vous allez devoir manger la
réponse or à chaque fois celui qui a
mangé la réponse qui a fini la réponse
d'accord il est il est qualifié il y
aura un éliminé à chaque fois la mode
made man made man man et à la fin il
n'en restera qu'un voici la première
question vous jouez avec nous bien sûr
que non selon un term propre aux gens
qui ont l'humour non par exemple
isabelle morini-bosc côte il n'a pas de
problème il n'y a pas deux y'a pas de
quoi le circuit de soucy beebeejaun
celle ci est complètement souci je sais
qu alors je sais qu'à date n'aime pas
les sur le poisson cru local gâte et
éliminé d'office ou chez moi j'ai mon
seul souci est elle réellement je ne
dirai qu'elle en dégustation c'est
sûrement là
alors j'ai deux contraints de faire un
petit trou du moment non mais c'est ça
vous avez mais c'est vrai j'ai un petit
trou du couple samedi
tous avaient un petit coin un petit trou
du coup mais depuis tout petit et ça me
donne un vrai que vous avez quelle est
l'autre nom de la foudre quel est
l'autre nom de la
[Applaudissements]
j'ai en entier
alors
j'ai mangé un bout mais après senna va
ça va moi j'ai leclerc à brive bush et
bien il aura mangé au mans 38 brown aura
qualifié bas et haut c'est pas la petite
bête qui va mal mais bon début mais j'ai
mis le souci qui est crédité large pays
ne sera pas là dedans il des trucs qui
me va manger ou qui pose un petit peu
courtois pareloup voilà merci là bas at
an plus tôt je vais vous dire de la moc
est disqualifié à hawija la madeleine on
dit souvent que matthieu delormeau a
pris le pas les melons
non j'aime ou j'aime le melon volante at
il faut finir le melon finir leur plaît
allez prenez tout le monde le melon
c'est bon vous allez crever arrêté
arrêté jeudi
alors on n'est pas avec un goûter avec
les motards c'est cécile verrait allait
y aller alors qu'est-ce que vous criez
lorsque vous fait mal c'est non
jean-michel de la qualité j'ai une
qualité c'est morrow qualifié qu'à
syndicalisés mon mini boss qualifiés et
nora ces bombes rues larges et vous êtes
disqualifié à doha ne mangez pas merci
j'en ai pris
quel est le nom du piquet qui sert à
fixer une dans une tente de camping dans
le sol une sardine c'est un derby
brescia bon c'est bon t'as toujours
détenus
merci éliminer les agréments et les
bateaux ont reculé au bon recul et merci
lorsqu'on est au bord de la colère
qu'est ce qui nous est donné
est ce que nous avons tourné ce sont
malades
c'est bon j'ai un peu ouais c'est bon
russell a tancé une au groupe depuis peu
les nerfs on apprécie t sont complétés
l'expression suivante on n'attrape pas
les mouches avec du cfc gilles verdez et
thierry moreau qui joue qu'en finale
puis on a découvert la semaine dernière
que sur le pied jean-michel l'air avait
sonné au niger en avoir c'est juste un
morceau le plus c'est jules vallès la
gagner je suis désolé l'écueil séduit
verdasco vainqueur quoi